[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue sur tv 78 pour votre
émission le 7-8 week-end le principe
vous le connaissez de l'actualité mais
aussi des loisirs pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines voici le
programme de ce 1er octobre
une opération nettoyons la nature est
elle en cours ce jeudi les élèves du
collège alexandre dumas se sont
mobilisés pour ramasser les déchets
autour de leur établissement nous sommes
allés leur prêter main forte cette année
encore l'université versailles saint
quentin en yvelines s'associer à
l'événement national de la nuit du droit
le rendez vous est donné lundi soir au
tribunal judiciaire de versailles marina
boursiers doyen de la faculté de droit
de sciences politiques de l'ue vs qu est
notre invité
et puis la sortie du nouvel album de
lady gaga quel rapport avec les yvelines
vous me direz bien la star américaine se
produisait virtuellement ce jeudi au
centre commercial parly 2 un concert en
live depuis les etats-unis et retransmis
dans 21 sites du groupe ouest file à
travers le monde
il se sera tout à l'heure dans la partie
loisirs avec sont fiers représentants
bixente n'a rien senti stéphane mongeau
bixente 11 ans grégory est votre mission
si vous l'acceptez encore aujourd'hui
c'est donner envie à nos téléspectateurs
et blinois de sortir dans les yvelines
quel est le menu du jour on parlera
cirque lapins crétins et retombe à un
phare le passé aussi et ce sera tout à
l'heure dans le 7-8 week end
[Musique]
mais d'abord l'actualité ce nouveau
conseil communautaire pour
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines les 76 élus et des douze
communes de la collectivité était
appelée à se réunir pour une séance en
visioconférence ce jeudi 25 points
étaient à l'ordre du jour à retenir dans
ce qui a été voté la création du réseau
sky shops sky enseignement supérieur et
entreprises avec l'ambition de
rapprocher davantage les mondes
universitaires et entrepreneuriale et
puis à l'approbation de deux conventions
priori blinn le programme de rénovation
urbaine du département des yvelines elle
le conseil départemental va apporter son
financement dans deux grands projets 22
millions d'euros pour la rénovation du
quartier du bois de l'étang à la
verrière qui prévoit la réhabilitation
de 400 logements 212 seront détruits et
de nouveaux logements également
construit vous le voyez sassetot
quartier du bois de l'étang vous voyez à
l'image et puis 23 millions d'euros pour
le quartier des petits prêts à elancourt
68 logements détruits des rénovations
extérieures un désenclavement du
quartier une concertation sera lancée
sur ce projet à elancourt justement des
élèves du collège alexandre dumas se
sont mobilisés pour l'opération
nettoyons la nature de nombreuses
classes ont pendant une heure ramasser
les déchets aux alentours de leur
établissement et bixente vous êtes allés
leur prêter main-forte c'est ça c'est ça
j'étais moins apprêtée qu'aujourd'hui
mais je suis en pleine forme aussi je
vous propose de regarder tout de suite
ce reportage bonjour à tous ce matin je
vous retrouve de la rédaction de tv 78
comme vous voyez il est haut il n'y a
pas encore grand monde nous aujourd'hui
on va partir avec notre téléphone une
petite vos propre à deux caméras on va
participer à l'opération nettoyons la
planète avec des enfants du collège
alexandre dumas c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
li na c'est ton vieux mégots douche
bistrot cycle c'est manade d'accord et
tout le reste on reste
donc là on vient de faire un petit
briefing avec tous les élèves et on est
parti pour la le ramassage on a vu qu'il
y avait des sacs spéciaux pour le
recyclage pour les choses comme sur un
cycle pas un sac spécial pour les mégots
notamment qui me disant à se dégrader
le sac des mégots jetés des mégots
ils sont tous sur un petit espace je
crois qu'il va être bien nettoyer je
trouvais un truc avec encore du café et
ayant copains il a trouvé même un
marteau dans les buissons
et joindre remarqué que les gens jettent
à tout et n'importe quoi moi j'ai trouvé
beaucoup de plastique beaucoup de trucs
comme ça des bouteilles mais beaucoup de
cannes est un peu trop est beaucoup trop
de nego là les mégots et romain trouve à
en perdre de vue regarder à chaque fois
en masse lui sont faits mais on peut pas
un collection pas pour ça qu'il va être
remplies avant la fin
[Rires]
et la ccq là
on est avec n'a elle en a presque fini
notre ramassage ça fait à peu près 45
minutes et de toute façon on peut pas
faire plus puisque les sacs sont
quasiment tous pleins
les gants vous allez surtout bienvenue à
vailima pour moi après je vous redonne
amarres avec isabelle et bling
professeur deux ps au collège et
organisatrice de cet événement du coup
moi avec mon groupe nous on a ramassé
pas mal de soucis de tête je peux
compter à peu près 15 à 20 kg avec mon
groupe donc isabelle comment ça s'est
passé pour les autres groupes déjà ce
matin et comment ça va se passer pour le
reste de l'opération alors les valaisans
groupe là j'ai pas j'ai pas leurs
résultats je vous ai vu revenir avec les
bras et charger des sacs pleins des
caddies d'une grande barre de fer on n'a
eu qu'à le groupe ce matin à lutter quel
groupe tout à l'heure on puisqu'elle
groupe demain donc pour les résultats ce
sera demain donc moi je vous retrouve en
plateau directement pour faire un petit
débrief avec vous demain c'est
aujourd'hui vendredi puisque vous étiez
dans cette opération ce jeudi premier
retour d'expérience mais chaîne ses
premiers retours c'était bien moi je
n'avais pas de gants malheureusement
mais vous avez pu voir que les aveux
étaient bien équipés et est-ce qu'on va
le bilan du coût de cette opération j'ai
le bilan sous les yeux pour les six
classes de 6e il ya eu 7 121 kg ramasser
parmi ceux-ci 121 kg
151,2 recyclables 134 kg de verre métal
verre et métaux pilé et 2 kg de mégots
et on peut noter aussi un matelas tapis
une moto en plastique un peu un tabouret
ya plein de choses que l'on dit ah bravo
aux élèves du collège alexandre dumas
qui ont participé à cette opération
on va parler à présent de cet événement
qui revient un temps impacté par la
crise sanitaire c'est la nuit du droit
qui se déroule ce 4 octobre c'est un
événement national auquel s'associe à
lui vs qu à partir de 17h30 ce lundi la
faculté de droit et de sciences
politiques donnent rendez vous au
tribunal judiciaire de versailles sous
l'égide du conseil constitutionnel c'est
en partenariat avec la cour
administrative d'appel de versailles le
barreau de versailles et pour en parler
marié à boursier est avec nous par
visioconférence bonjour
vous êtes le doyen de la faculté de
droit et de sciences politiques de l'ue
vs qu il faut rappeler que le 4 octobre
c'est la date anniversaire de la
constitution de 1958 pourquoi une nuit
du droit qu'elles sont finalement les
objectifs de cet événement bon je crois
qu'à l'origine l'objectif du président
du conseil constitutionnel arrive en
2007 était précisément de rendre
peut-être le droit plus accessible et de
dire au fond aux citoyens à quel point
il est essentiel à la vie d'une
démocratie comme la nôtre et joueront
que c'est le message le message qui est
transmis ainsi autour de la date du 4
octobre je fais référence évidemment à
la date de réduction de la constitution
du 4 octobre 1958 lempire de laquelle
vème république fonctionne actuellement
et cette année le thème c'est
tocqueville notre contemporain la nuit
est consacrée au philosophe et homme
politique du 19e siècle alexis de
tocqueville pourquoi lui dédier cette
nuit justement je crois que c'est sans
doute au regard de son ampleur
intellectuelle philosophique de son
caractère 7 et sociales dans le
politique un bon siècle au 19e siècle
comme vous l'avait dit et tocqueville
après senti très tôt dès les années 1830
1835 le fort mouvement démocratique et
c'est parti aux états unis on est revenu
on est dit-on sur fan des ouvrages de la
démocratie en amérique et donc c'est un
précurseur qui a réfléchi et pensé sur
vos questions démocratiques en influence
finalement les législateurs de son
époque je crois que tout cela justifie
autour des raisons on a donné de cette
nuit du droit justifie de le mettre à
l'honneur comme un grand penseur d'un
grand philosophe français
avec un droit qui se déroulent cette
année au tribunal judiciaire de
versailles on a vu des images d'une
précédente union droit qui était à la
salle du jeu de paume c'est toujours à
versailles le programme va démarrer à
partir de 18 heures le rendez vous est
même fixée à partir de 17h30 à ce
tribunal judiciaire quel est le
programme
oui alors le programme et constitue en
effet une arrivée vers 17h30 pour
respecter les consignes sanitaires et
puis hein g qui est une conférence débat
autour des grandes thématiques sur
lesquelles on a réfléchi et que nous a
transmis tocqueville de la démocratie de
la question des esclavages avec des
intervenants comme vous le soulignez et
du tribunal judiciaire avec un bond de
l'université et de la cour
administrative d'appel et puis le
barreau de versailles donc toutes les
professions juridiques et judiciaires et
universitaire réfléchissent en apportant
chacune au un éclairage différent sur
la montagne il faut réserver pour y
participer mais vous me disiez avant le
début de cette émission que les places
étaient comptés il en reste et il ne
reste plus beaucoup oui tout à fait je
crois qu'il ya très très peu de place
mais encore décourageons pas ce qu'ils
feraient des faits niés
merci marié ma bourse est d'avoir été
avec nous
doyen de la faculté de droit de sciences
politiques de l'université versailles
saint quentin et la nuit du droit je
vous le rappelle c'est donc le 4 octobre
tribunal judiciaire de versailles
d'accueil à partir de 17h30 est un
événement qui viendra ouvrir une
nouvelle semaine dans les yvelines avant
cela retour sur les faits qui ont marqué
la semaine en cours du 27 septembre au
1er octobre l'actualité binois ce qui
est résumé par céline sort de la voix de
michael et demi d'euros
[Musique]
dans l'actualité cette semaine un bébé
si dating a pris place à montigny le
bretonneux au total une quarantaine de
familles et 56 baby sitter entre 16 et
25 ans se sont rencontrés à l'université
versailles saint quentin a organisé son
3e symposium sport santé à l'ufr simone
veil en compagnie de sportifs de
chercheurs et de professionnels de santé
l'occasion de revenir sur l'institut
santé passeport connecter un
établissement dédié au sport et au
handicap prévu pour 2024 aux mureaux une
vingtaine d'associations se sont réunis
devant la médiathèque de montigny le
bretonneux à l'occasion de la sixième
édition de la journée des possibles
l'objectif était de sensibiliser aux
enjeux environnementaux
le vainqueur pourrait fermer sur la
ligne j qui relie paris saint lazare à
l'ouest parisien c'est ce qu'a annoncé
la cgt cheminots montée vexin en cause
un nouveau contrat ile-de-france
mobilité voulu par la région mardi avait
lieu le forum des associations à
l'université versailles saint quentin le
plaisir de constater un retour à la vie
étudiante et à la vie normale tous les
étudiants peuvent maintenant revenir en
cours en présentiel
[Musique]
le sourire et la bonne humeur de bixente
mais rien senti steban de retour en
plateau pour ses idées de sorties
loisirs du week-end mais c'est à suivre
d'abord si je vous dis pokerface bad
romaine ce chaland vous me répondez
forcément bixente forcément l'immense
lady gaga lady ya effectivement et
l'artiste américaine sort aujourd'hui
son deuxième album avec le crooner tony
bennett et pour l'occasion elle se
produisait ce jeudi dans les yvelines
enfin presque la star était en concert
effectivement aux états unis mais un
live retransmis simultanément dans 21
centres commerciaux dont celui de parly
2 dont 21 centres ouest fils et je crois
bien qu'elle ya mis le feu regarder
[Musique]
en live en direct des états unis aux
chaînés rocancourt le centre commercial
westfield a vu se produire lady gaga la
star américaine dévoilée en avant
première leurs forces elles son nouvel
album ce live ce soir diffusé à we still
parly ii est un événement vraiment
unique puisque c'est un événement
hybride qui allie à la fois en fait le
digital et l'expérience physique
il a effectivement cessé dans la lignée
de la stratégie de notre groupe de
vouloir en fait toujours répondre aux
attentes de nos clients qui veulent
aujourd'hui des expériences sensorielles
émotionnel ou plateformes digitales sur
laquelle on réunit en fait ce soir et
c'est ce qui est extraordinaire les fans
de lady gaga et en même temps nos
clients nos visiteurs de nos centres qui
sont des réelles destinations dans le
monde 21 centres du groupe dans 10 pays
différents dont deux dans les yvelines a
parlé de la jauge permettait
d'accueillir jusqu'à 500 personnes
un concert pour découvrir la deuxième
collaboration entre lady gaga et tony
bennett n'a vu l'opportunité de venir du
coup
cet événement est donc on a sauté sur
l'occasion parce qu'on n'était jamais
bien un événement comme ça là parce que
j'aime les dégâts parce que je les
découvertes dans jeune star is born et
depuis j'apprécie beaucoup c'est une
occasion de se détendre après des mois
pour piquer vous savez bien la soirée
était aussi l'occasion d'un appel au
fonds pour les deux associations des
artistes l'album est disponible depuis
ce 1er octobre
[Musique]
bon là on est plutôt sur des chansons de
charme des chansons d'amour duquel le
fait cet album avec le crooner tony
bennett est ce qu'il ya un air que vous
préférez vous de lady gaga center face
ou paparazzi peut-être vous voulez en
chanter un air n'ont peut-être pas
dû faire cette approche alors les idées
de sorties du week end à présent 10 gmt
et s'est tellement nationale c'est les
nuits blanches qui se déroule à paris un
peu partout en france et aussi dans la
ville de versailles oui à versailles cet
événement se traduit sous le nom de nuit
de la création
la ville souhaite faire valoir donc la
création contemporaine pour cela d'un
afflux différents une quinzaine de
projets éphémères sont à découvrir de
20h à 1h du matin pour retrouver la
programmation complète rendez vous donc
sur le site internet de la ville quant à
nous nous recevons des élèves et anciens
élèves de l'école des beaux-arts de
versailles on a un premier groupe
infinito bonjour
vous êtes donc sur le lieu de votre
projet à l'atelier numérique et ensuite
il y a diana ou plutôt une terre que
c'est votre nom d'artiste bonjour
vous êtes de chez vous puisque le musée
lambinet où vous exposez demain est
fermée aujourd'hui on va commencer donc
avec mathilde veronica et mickaël pour
le collectif infinito est ce que vous
pouvez me présenter ce que vous allez
faire ici du coup à l'atelier numérique
oui alors en fait nous pour la nuit de
la création on a repris l'idée très
prépondérant des jardins de le nôtre qui
lie à versailles et on en a refait
un jardin en pied en reprenant les
motifs et donc on a planté nous mêmes un
par un tous les bras en papier et c'est
ce qu'on présente dans l'espace de
l'atelier numérique ça s'appelle mais
par ont suscité les prestiges s'enfuit
pourquoi ce nom en fait
alors ce nom est extrait d'un poème
qui parle justement de la ville de
versailles et de la sensation que l'on
ressent lorsque l'on marche dans cette
ville chargée d'histoire
donc ça nous a beaucoup inspiré comme
nous notre installation les visiteurs
pour marcher dessus du coup ce poème
nous a inspirés pour
notre installation c'était c'était tout
dit super bas quant à vous diana du coup
vous avez vous serez à quelques
centaines de mètres de là au musée
lambinet comme je le disais vous allez
créer une pelouse aussi à partir de
vêtements pouvez vous nous expliquer
votre démarche
alors en fait ce que j'ai fait c'est que
j'ai pu comment collectionner ou ramener
des vêtements en fait qui appartenait à
des amis à moi ou à d'autres personnes
que je ne connais pas forcément et je me
suis mis tout simplement aller coudre
tous ensemble puis les étaler sur une
vingtaine de mètres voilà comment vous
est venue l'idée
alors je suis quelqu'un qui garde à peu
près tout et n'importe quoi je stocke de
manière massive et particulièrement les
vêtements et j'ai toujours voulu en
faire quelque chose parce que c'est vrai
que les vêtements c'est quand même
porteur d'histoire et partez en
d'identité et du coup enfin c'est voulu
comme ça
merci merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup diana ou plutôt une terre
que d'avoir été avec nous et aussi au
groupe infinito on pourra donc vous
retrouver à l'atelier du numérique pour
le collectif infinito au musée lambinet
pour la pelouse artificielle du terc
parmi les autres sites il ya le carré de
la farine sur le marché de notre dame et
même votre école l'école des beaux-arts
de versailles qui n'accueille pas moins
de quatre projets pour en savoir plus
donc comme je le disais rendez vous sur
le site internet de versailles merci à
vous inviter lucent et merci à vous
toujours pas d'air de lady gaga à nous
chanter
jour pas y en a qui viennent vous laisse
réfléchir peut être le pari avant la fin
de cette émission alors on va rester
dans la cité royale tout jouer et cette
nouveauté dans les jardins du château de
versailles une nouveauté originale est
pour le moins drôle oui il n'ya plus que
il n'a plus que la merveilleuse alice
qui peut voir un lapin gambader dans les
jardins du château averse à une
application vous permet de rencontrer
même plusieurs et vous verrez qu'ils
sont un peu crétin ses lapins
[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on se
retrouve dans les jardins du château de
versailles à la découverte d'une
nouvelle application les lapins crétins
à versailles elle a été créée par
ubisoft et dans un objectif faire
découvrir le jardin à toute la famille
alors on y va
première mission commence dès le
parterre d'eau objectif repousser
l'invasion en montgolfière des lapins
contre le château une fois la mission
réussie on apprend que ce parterre
accueilla le premier vol habité en
ballon de l'histoire en 10min jeu basé
sur de la réalité augmentée il est
possible de découvrir les jardins ainsi
que leur histoire
par ailleurs en réalisant de bons scores
vous débloquerez des éléments
cosmétiques pour habiller votre lapin
comme à la cour du roi soleil
alors nous nous retrouvons avec paul
schene directeur adjoint de la
communication du château de versailles
bonjour bonjour pouvez-vous on peut nous
expliquer comment est née cette
application
pour quelles raisons avez vous mis en
place cette application lapins crétins à
versailles
ça fait presque un an qu'on travaille
sur ce projet et c'est vrai que pour
nous ce château de versailles c'était
très important de concevoir de proposer
un produit une offre culturelle qui
puisse s'adresser à tous les publics y
compris aux plus jeunes publics et aux
familles qui sont nombreux à venir à
versailles toute l'année et l'objectif
c'était aussi de mettre un peu de gaming
c'est quelque chose d'important toutes
ses mécaniques de jeu elles sont
importantes aujourd'hui dans la vie des
publics et donc de proposer un contenu
qui soit à la fois ludiques et
culturelles on apprend plein de choses
lors de sa visite au château de
versailles est donc déjà été produit par
ubisoft
comment comment est-ce que ça s'est mis
en place en effet ce jeu a été réalisée
dans le cadre d'un partenariat entre
ubisoft et le château de versailles et
c'était à la fois la volonté d'ubisoft
de travailler avec un site reconnu
mondialement comme le château de
versailles et la volonté du château de
versailles de proposer et de bénéficier
de l'expertisé en termes de gaming de
jeux vidéo d'ubisoft et j'imagine qu'une
bise à peut-être dû venir sur place wii
ubisoft est venu à plusieurs reprises
dans les jardins du château de
versailles pour préparer ce jeu réalisé
dans le cadre d'un mécénat de
compétences d'ubisoft pour le château de
versailles donc bien sûr il ya un petit
jeu de labyrinthe hydraulique
qui se passe au niveau de la fontaine de
la tonne que vous pouvez observer ici il
ya également un puzzle au niveau de
l'orangerie il ya également des
mécaniques de jeu avec des topiaires ou
des mécaniques de jeu avec les fontaines
du bosquet du théâtre d'auch et bien
merci beaucoup pour cet entretien nous
nous continuons tout de suite notre
aventure dans les jardins du château
alors suivez nous
les lapins crétins à versailles est
disponible gratuitement sur toutes les
plateformes mobiles tels qu apple store
google plaire et accessible dans 5
langues différentes
comptez environ une heure et demie le
temps de déambuler et finir les
activités pour terminer le jeu
bon ben voila je ne trouve au bosquet du
théâtre d'auch et j'ai fini le dernier
mini jeux je me suis bien amusé et j'ai
appris plusieurs anecdotes sur les
jardins par contre comme vous allez le
voir le look du lapin c'est vraiment pas
ça
[Musique]
et je crois qu antoine nous a envoyé une
petite image de son lapin on peut voir
comment comment vous la trouvez vous la
mettre en plein écran parce que là je la
vois je la vois mal à eux c'est pas mal
c'est pas mal de l'idée oui les bras
voir antoine durand a pour ce reportage
et vous l'avait accompagné à bixente
pour ce reportage au château de
versailles avec les lapins crétins donc
direction désormais les mureaux où on
lève le chapiteau ce week end il ajouté
en effet ça fait presque 20 ans que
chaque année les mureaux accueille le
festival international du cirque des
numéros d'acrobatie de voltige de
dressage de chiens et bien entendu de
clowns venus du monde entier pour
éblouir les spectateurs pendant deux
jours quatre représentations sont
prévues samedi 15h et 20h dimanche 11h
et 15h30 et j'oubliais parmi les dix
numéros d'exception prévue le
traditionnel numéro de magie de quoi
vous donner des étoiles plein les yeux à
propos de magie vous nous proposez à
présent un voyage dans le temps
direction l'époque napoléonienne oui
exactement ce sera les 9 et 10 octobre
prochains rambouillet se met à l'heure
impérial l'événement est organisé par la
commune de rambouillet qui ouvre le
palais de rome le centre des monuments
nationaux qui donne l'accès lui au
château de rambouillet et la bergerie
nationale pour du coup la bergerie
nationale ce n'est pas sans ses 22 cents
c'est bien trois cents personnes voit
son père seulement être habillé aux
couleurs de l'époque napoléonienne mais
grégory et ça s'appelle donc alain
rambouillet à leur impérial et voici un
petit aperçu de ce qui vous attend on
immerge véritablement les gens grâce à
des scènes de vie quotidienne par
exemple à la bergerie nationale il y
aura un bivouac militaire où on va
vraiment découvrir le quotidien de ces
campements du 19e siècle au château on
va découvrir et participer aux
distractions de l'empereur lorsqu'il
venait séjourner ici en ville on va
pouvoir avoir accès au palais du roi de
rome à une boutique de mode reconstitué
ça permet une belle immersion donc et on
pourra vous y retrouver avec votre plus
beau costume j'ai essayé de réserver un
petit apparats de napoléon pour leur
talent aux cases estime de napoléon
d'eau pour bixente on termina dans un
autre château à buc oui avec son très
reconnu festival de la bd le 28e au
programme des rencontres et des
dédicaces avec des auteurs venus de
belgique de suisse d'allemagne de plus
loin je peux citer notamment la slovénie
la serbie ou encore le maroc et ça me
donne bien envie moi personnellement de
voir ce que donne le monde de la bd là
bas et ce sera donc la semaine prochaine
le week-end prochain au menu un ce
festival de la bd de vue qui est un
classique de la rentrée chaque année à
buc merci bixente c'est déjà la fin de
cette émission se retrouvent vendredi
prochain il y aura notamment je crois au
programme la fête de la science qui va
largement animé le week-end prochain à
saint quentin en yvelines mais aussi
dans tout les yvelines oui à la
commanderie par exemple à la commanderie
qui est située à elancourt et on en
reparlera la semaine prochaine lundi
bien sûr ne manquez pas le retour du
journal pour être au fait de toute
l'actualité locale dans les yvelines et
d'ici là passez un très bon week-end sur
tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]